progenitors like the early on
developmental stems
so you start from one zygote and that's
a totipotent
cell type it can do anything you then
differ you know that cell divides
divides divides
and then every cell division is
leading to specialization where you now
have
a mesodermal lineage and ectodermal
lineage and endodermal lineage
that basically leads to different parts
of your day or your body
the ectoderm will basically give rise to
your skin
ecto means outside derm is skin
so ectoderm but it also gives rise to
your neurons and your whole brain so
that's a lot of ectoderm
mesoderm gives rise to your internal
organs including
the vasculature and you know your muscle
and stuff like that
so you basically have this progressive
differentiation
and then if you look further further
down that lineage you basically have one
lineage that will give rise to both your
muscle
and your bone but also your fat
and if you go further down the lineage
of your fat
you basically have your white fat cells
these are the cells that store energy so
when you eat a lot but you don't
exercise too much there's an excess
a set of calories excess energy what you
do with those
you basically create you spend a lot of
that energy to create these high energy
molecules
lipids which you can then
burn when you need them on a rainy day
so that leads to obesity if you don't
exercise and if you overeat
because your body is like oh great i
have all these calories
i'm going to store them oh more calories
i'm going to store them too oh more
calories
and the you know 42
of european chromosomes have
a predisposition to storing fat which
was
selected probably in
the you know food scarcity periods
like basically as we were exiting africa
you know before and during the ice ages
you know there was probably a selection
to those individuals who made it north
to basically be able to store energy you
know a lot more energy
so you basically now have this lineage
that is deciding whether you want to
store energy in your white fat
or burn energy in your base fat
it turns out that your fat is you know
like we um we have such a bad view of
fat fat is your best friend
fat can both store all these excess
lipids that would be otherwise
circulating through your
you know body and causing damage but it
can also burn calories directly
if you have too much of energy you can
just choose to just burn some of that as
heat
so basically when you're cold you're
burning energy
to basically warm your body up and
you're burning all these lipids and
you're burning all these calories
so what we basically found is that
across the board
genetic variants associated with obesity
across many of these regions
were all enriched repeatedly in
mesenchymal stem cell enhancers
so that gave us a hint as to which of
these genetic variants
was likely driving this whole
association
and we ended up with this one genetic
variant
called rs1421085
and that genetic variant out of the 89
was the one that we predicted to be
causal for the disease
wow so going back to those steps first
step is figure out the relevant tissue
based on the global enrichment second
step is figure out
the causal variant among
many variants in this linkage
disequilibrium in this co-inherited
block
between these recombination hotspots
these boundaries of these inherited
blocks
that's the second step the third step is
once you know that causal variant try to
figure out
what is the motif that is disrupted by
that causal variant basically how does
it act
variants don't just disrupt elements
they disrupt the binding of specific
regulators
so basically the third step there was
how do you find the motif
that is responsible like the gene
regulatory
word the building block of gene
regulation that is responsible
for that disregulatory event and the
fourth step is finding out
what regulator normally binds that motif
and is now no longer able to bind and
then once you have the regulator can you
then try to figure out how to
what after it developed how to fix it
that's exactly right you now know how to
intervene you have basically
a regulator you have a gene that you can
then perturb and you say well maybe that
regulator
has a global role in obesity i can
perturb the regulator
just to clarify when we say perturb like
on the scale of a human life can a human
being be helped
of course of course yeah so i guess
understanding is the first step
no no but perturbed basically means you
now develop therapeutics pharmaceutical
therapeutics against that
or you develop other types of
intervention that affect the expression
of that gene
you